wow Fox News and Dominion voting systems
have settled Dominion's
1.6 billion dollar defamation suit
against Fox News they have settled it at
787 million dollars just as the trial
was starting this will require and did
require Fox News in writing to concede
that they got some things wrong AKA lied
but it will not require them to make
on-air apologies and we're going to talk
about that now as we talked about
yesterday and the news yesterday was
there is not going to be a settlement
within minutes of that episode going
live they reached a settlement what we
talked about yesterday was the to some
degree lose-lose aspect to this for Fox
News if you settle it you're admitting
wrongdoing whether you admit wrongdoing
in writing or not it's understood that
you're not fighting for what you believe
to be true to the end of the tri you're
settling you're saying yeah okay fine
we'll pay we'll pay because we did the
thing at least to some degree that we
are accused of doing and of course they
can try to wash it by saying it's not
that we believe we did anything wrong
but it became clear that they were going
to drag this out for political reasons
we're the victims okay fine but you're
saying we're gonna pay
if you refuse
and you go into a four or even six week
trial you see six weeks of headlines
including potentially more Discovery uh
elements texts phone calls who knows
what could come out and it could be even
more damaging potentially so as deadline
reports Fox News agrees to pay 787
million dollars to settle the Dominion
false election claims case fox has
admitted to telling lies said the voting
systems CEO the Delaware Superior Court
Judge Eric Davis overseeing the case
made an announcement that quote the
parties have resolved their case
offering no additional details news of
the subtle settlement was strategically
made public right before Wall Street
ceased trading for the day it is going
to be 787 million dollars 787 and a half
million in fact uh fox has admitted to
telling lies about Dominion that it
caused enormous damage to my company our
employees and the customers we serve
said Dominion CEO John polos nothing can
make up for that Fox News is not
required to air an apology or retraction
however Fox was quick to address the
settlement in crafted language that
softly walks back the claims made by
hosts and guests that the 2020 election
was stolen from Donald Trump there's a
couple different aspects to this that I
think are very very important to talk
about one of them is that we have to
distinguish Free Speech claims from
defamation
this is not about Free Speech this is
about a responsibility for a public
platform the size of Fox News
not to defame others and when we talk
about defamation we're talking about
false claims damaging to one's
reputation were it true that Dominion
participated in rigging the election to
steal it from trump it would be damaging
to their reputation but it would be
accurate and therefore it would not be
defamation and so the Crux of this is
inextricably interwoven with the lies
told about the 2020 election Trump
didn't win Biden did and whatever story
you had about
cured ballots or sauteed ballots or
grilled ballots and stuff to you know a
double double stuffed crust ballots or
whatever or it was dominion and
smartmatic that rigged it or whatever
it's all part of a bigger lie now we
have video here of lawyers for Dominion
uh who are taking the perspective that
lies have consequences and that is true
whatever you think about 800 million
dollars nearly is that the right amount
or
lies have consequences is the
perspective that they are taking today's
settlement
of
787 million
million represents then
an accountability
lies have consequences
the truth does not know red or blue
today I want to also be really clear
that this is not going to take down Fox
News there is a smartmatic defamation
suit as well and that could get settled
for hundreds of millions as well it's
it's not going to take down Fox News
financially we then get to the question
is it going to take down Fox News in
other ways yesterday I told you that fox
has major negotiations coming up with
three major cable providers Fox unlike
most cable channels doesn't really
depend on Advertising so much as they
have negotiated fees per cable
subscriber I have a cable subscription I
don't watch Fox News but a couple bucks
I believe somewhere between two and four
dollars of my monthly payment goes to
Fox because that's the deal that fox has
negotiated so there's the question of
whether in in the under the black cloud
of this settlement and future lawsuits
that continue whether Fox is going to be
able to negotiate the same sort of deal
that may hurt them and then secondly
there's the question of wow now that
they've paid nearly 800 million to
settle a defamation claim in which they
lied to Their audience maybe they will
lose their audience but of course I
don't think that that's going to happen
the Fox News viewer actually sees Fox
News as the victim here by and large I
want to play a couple of interesting
clips for you here is um Fox Media
analyst Howard Kurtz appearing with Neil
Cavuto just moments after the
announcement of the settlement and uh
take a look at what he had to say this
had to do with the idea that Dominion
voting machines and former president
Trump and his allies made this case on
Fox and elsewhere where somehow stealing
votes from Donald Trump and flipping
them to Joe Biden that's obviously false
those were conspiracy theories but the
case would have revolved around uh you
know whether Fox had done dujilliness
whether it was Reckless whether it was
simply reporting as the network contends
on an extremely newsworthy matter argued
by the former then president of the
United States himself so whether the
amount of the settlement will leak often
it doesn't maybe that's part of the deal
but at this point that's what we know
okay so a couple different things one
reaction to that clip was wow look
that's Fox News admitting on Fox news
that the stuff that they said was
obviously untrue Kurtz really downplays
it significantly he said oh you know
there were there were some statements
made which were not true this was was
months and months of coverage on both
the news and opinion sides giving voice
to the wackiest of wacky you know Sydney
Powell and Mike pillow and all these
other people it was more than just ah
some things were said that weren't true
that being said Fox News is going to
minimize this incredibly and eventually
frame themselves as the victims I want
to show you an article that was
published about the settlement yesterday
it's fewer than 200 words long it
mentions that the judge praised Fox's
lawyers and it doesn't mention what the
settlement amount was the article is
called Fox news media Dominion voting
systems reach agreement over defamation
lawsuit
Dominion filed a 1.6 billion lawsuit
against fox in 2021
Delaware Superior Court Judge Eric Davis
praised both parties for the handling of
their case quote I've been on the bench
since 2010 I think this is the best
lawyering I've had ever I would be proud
to be your judge in the future the
settlement came as a trial was scheduled
to launch this week with a jury selected
earlier in the day the lawsuit stemmed
from coverage of the post-2020
presidential election and it became
media fodder then president Trump and
his allies challenged Joe Biden's
Victory some of them including members
of his legal team made false and
unsubstantiated claims against Dominion
voting systems and are the subject of
separate defamation lawsuits done end of
story you scroll down it's just ads okay
that's the full story not
Fox News has admitted in writing that
they signal boosted those claims Fox
News is going to pay nearly 800 million
dollars to get this to go away none of
that stuff is included this is the
summary the nice tidy summary of This by
Fox News so this is the way that it ends
with Dominion advantage to Dominion of
going this route also includes that
rather than a drawn out trial
potentially appeals and then trying to
collect the settlement they presumably
will have a much more direct path to
that 787 million dollars interestingly
just before the settlement was announced
Fox News lawyers through Trump and
allies under the bus I want to talk
about that next